no well first of all I mean there were
many times in my political career when
the presence of a streaker would have
been a very welcome guy volition so I
mean perfectly happy if it have been
graphically filmed but I think this is a
very very difficult question actually
about responsibilities within the media
and what are the rules and funnily
enough I've been talking a lot about
this recently because I it's it's also
something which from talking for the
politicians point of view of what I call
the tyranny of the protest which means
that if you have this you know if you
have this session on camera and let's
say kattiline you decide to go and throw
something or shout or you know cause a
erection and this is a you know that is
what will get publicity and nothing else
will get publicity so you are they're
getting a lot of publicity the rest of
the class might as well not exist you
know so it's a real problem
it's it's it's it's the way it happens
today and the reason why it's wrong by
the way and this is the important point
to come to your point because you see
the media would say look it's free media
we should report whatever we want to
report but that's not really the point
the point actually is to have a sense of
responsibility measured also by what
this thing represents let me explain
what I mean by that you see I think that
if Pastor Jones had five million
Americans in his church and was burning
the Koran I think even though it would
be inflammatory for the media to film
that I would argue you can't possibly
not film that that must be a significant
section of American opinion I have the
Church of five million people and here's
they had a bit standing up and burning
the Koran well that is news actually
because that must indicate something
about American society right the
irresponsibility actually is because
he's got thirty followers and it doesn't
actually indicate anything about
American society other than what we know
by any society which is the rare except
drinking crazy people in any society and
that's the problem so the problem is
that the fact that someone comes out and
does something that is you know
impactful the the concept of
responsibility is not about you know
covering things that are uncomfortable
for people because that is going to
broad the concept is to have some
measurement of its validity in terms of
it what it says about the society
otherwise you know if you film and this
is what happened of course you film or
you you you create this movement around
the past of burning the Koran and people
in Pakistan or Afghanistan are thinking
this guy's speaking for America because
this is a head of some Church in America
right and that's what I think is
difficult about but these are really
difficult questions and incidentally the
way the debate that is not being had in
the world today in the Western world at
least is responsibility and I'm biased
on this because I have to handle them
but you know responsibility in a media
in within the media is a major major
issue because the debate between
politics and the media is is really
really bad now and it's it's it's
starting to corrupt the discussion of
issues in a sensible and rational way
and it's also because what then happens
the corollary of what you're talking
about is if you want to run for office
anywhere in Europe today you get out
there with a message about immigrants
and you know Muslims and all the rest of
it and you can really start up you know
you you can get traction because you can
get the publicity so I think it is a
major part of what we need to debate out
here